- I actually don't know where to start.
I'm just, I'm so furious.
And I'm so sad for our country.
That they claim to be the
party of law and order.
The hypocrisy makes it
feel like ash in my mouth
to even say it.
Because there's no depth, no illegality
to which the president will not stoop.
It's astounding.
The president has completed
what appears to be
the first raft of pardons
in the lame-duck period.
It's a murderers' row of the unpardonable.
Though, an actual row of murderers
are probably less morally blameworthy
than the people that actually
received the pardons.
Actual war criminals
who were responsible for
killing innocent Iraqi citizens,
including women and children.
Ridiculously corrupt politicians,
like Chris Collins and Duncan Hunter,
who were convicted of
and were about to serve
extensive prison sentences
related to insider trading
and also embezzling campaign funds.
Including, but not limited to,
spending those campaign funds
on extramarital affairs.
Actual traitors to this country
like Paul Manafort,
who was a direct conduit to the Russians
through Konstantin Kilimnik
and Oleg Deripaska.
And, of course, the president's cronies.
Including, but not
limited to, Paul Manafort.
But also Roger Stone
and George Papadopoulos.
There's just no end to the depravity.
This is unprecedented in its
baseness, in its venality.
We've just never seen anything
like this in the US.
Effectively, every significant defendant
who refused to cooperate with
both the Mueller Investigation
and also just Main Justice
have now been pardoned.
The only exceptions being
Rick Gates and Michael Cohen,
both of whom actually testified
and cooperated against the president.
And this is tinpot, dictator,
Banana Republic level corruption.
If this seems like comic book villainy,
that's because it is.
This is not a close case.
This is not an issue of red versus blue.
This is just pure, flat out corruption.
And, I guess, let's
start with the bad news
because on some levels
this is worse than it appears.
It's not just that the
morally reprehensible
and actual criminals have been pardoned.
It's that this threatens
the very fabric of our justice system.
In part, because this
is just the opening act.
There's no reason to think
that President Trump
is going to stop with these pardons.
In fact, there's very good reason to think
that this is just out
there to get people tired.
That the worst pardons are yet to come.
And it's the usual suspects
who are the obvious candidates here.
There's no reason to
think that the president
will refrain from pardoning Jared Kushner;
pardoning Bill Barr;
pardoning himself, Ivanka, Don Junior;
Allen Weisselberg, the CFO
of the Trump Organization.
But President Trump
doesn't have those lines.
He doesn't feel shame.
And he doesn't give a damn
about political norms.
Because what happened here
is a really, really big deal.
President Trump is pardoning
a whole bunch of people
who engaged in criminality in furtherance
of the president's own agenda.
For his own campaign.
And for other reasons
that benefit President Trump personally.
Because the problem with pardoning people
who engage in actual criminality
for the benefit of the sitting president,
if the president is allowed
to pardon and absolve
guilt after the fact,
there's a million ways
for a sitting president to grift that.
Let's take an extreme example.
We all often talk about
how the president could kill
someone on Fifth Avenue,
but what if the president hired someone
to kill a political opponent
and then decided to pardon them.
Or a less extreme example.
Let's call it stochastic terrorism,
where the president just says,
"Hey, it'd be really great
"if someone killed my
main political rival."
And then if you actually
pardon that person,
which potentially the president could do,
well, then it just incentivizes
actual murder of political opponents.
And while that's obviously extreme,
Vladimir Putin has I tried this twice
with his main political
rival, Alexei Navalny.
And, obviously, there's
a state law issue here.
Murder is generally a state law crime.
So maybe the pardon wouldn't work,
but how about this.
What if the president
intentionally engaged
in all kinds of campaign
finance violations?
Getting, let's say, billions of dollars
for a campaign slush fund
and then just pardoned all the people
who engaged in campaign finance violations
for the benefit of the sitting president,
who would then have the benefit
of billions of dollars of campaign funds.
If the president can
pardon co-conspirators
or pardon those who engage in criminality
at the president's benefit,
or just simply hand out pardons
like Thank You cards,
there is no end to gaming the system.
And, of course, on the
other side of the aisle,
so far the Republicans have
been absolutely silent.
Those people who will jump over themselves
to fawn over this president.
Ben Shapiro, Mark Levin, Tucker Carlson
have said absolutely nothing.
Nothing.
And like I said,
this isn't a close case.
This is not my side versus yours.
This isn't an affront to
the actual rule of law.
Really, at this point,
only Ben Sasse has had the temerity
to even criticize the move
saying that "this is rotten to the core."
Well, gee.
Thanks, Ben.
Thank you for your service.
And by backing those words up
with absolutely no action whatsoever.
Because there's a lot of damage
that's actually going to keep happening
before January 20th gets here.
And there is absolutely nothing
that's in the works to try and stop this.
But I shouldn't criticize Ben Sasse.
At least he came forward publicly
and at least criticized the president.
Everybody else seems to be happy
just to sit idly by and silent.
And, unfortunately, it gets worse.
Contrary to what you might
read on Facebook or Twitter,
Trump is almost certainly not going
to face criminal scrutiny
for even pardoning Manafort or Stone,
or anybody else.
Absent actual evidence
that there was an explicit quid pro quo
between Trump and his co-conspirators,
there's not going to be
criminal repercussions.
There's just not.
And I don't think even
an aggressive attorney general
in the next administration
is going to change that.
It's an abuse of power.
The guardrail is impeachment.
And when you have a couple of days left
in the Trump presidency,
impeachment is no real
guardrail whatsoever.
So for all intents and purposes,
it's unlikely that President Trump
is going to face any kind of
real scrutiny as a
result of these actions.
And while these are uncharted waters,
absent very strong proof
of a separate crime
like extortion or bribery,
these pardons are not going
to be declared illegal.
And it's not even clear
that if you found this
separate criminality
that it could be declared illegal.
The parties themselves.
And don't expect future state or federal
prosecutions of Manafort or Stone.
The complications are
probably grave enough
that it's unlikely that they're going
to face punishment for
their actual crimes.
And, like I said,
the pardons will continue.
The message has been sent that
if you uphold your silence
against who is effectively a mafia don,
you're going to get a pardon.
You will be rewarded for your service
and contravention of justice.
There's no real silver lining there.
That die is cast.
That norm has been broken
and you can expect that
future administrations
are going to take note
if there are no real penalties
for abusing the pardon power this way.
And it's ironic, too.
Because, traditionally, the pardon power
has been grossly underused.
There are thousands of people who receive
grossly inappropriate
sentences every year.
For all the good that
the justice system does,
it does a lot of bad too.
Or at least it's often overzealous
in punishing crimes.
And there are a lot of
people who are in jail
that, arguably, should not be.
And, historically, presidents
are much more likely
to underuse the pardon power
than they are to overuse it.
And to date, we've never seen anything
like what President Trump has done.
But the whataboutism is strong.
People have pointed to the pardoning
of Marc Rich by President Clinton
and that pardon, rightfully,
sparked bipartisan outrage.
It sparked congressional inquiries.
This is not to say that
that particular pardon
was, in any way, just or correct.
People were rightly outraged about it.
But this is so much worse.
There was, and should have been,
political fallout for that pardon.
But what we're seeing
out of the Trump administration
is much, much worse.
It's dozens of individuals
who have a direct
connection to the president.
And the pardons being used in a way
that really does
undermine the rule of law.
And that's not an exaggeration.
Because it's going to change the way
that political institutions
use the pardon in the future.
And it's not going to get better,
unless there are real punishments.
Now I may be your discount John Krasinski,
but let me try it to give you
some good news here.
The first is that Paul Manafort
is not going to get his townhouses
or ostrich jackets back.
Under ex parte Garland,
A pardon does not restore
offices forfeited,
or property, or interest vested in others
in consequences of a
conviction and judgment.
So at least the Mueller Investigation
will still have turned a profit.
You also probably know that
these pardons don't really
affect state law prosecutions,
if there is indeed
state-based criminality.
We know that there are
ongoing investigations,
particularly in New York.
But I counsel you, don't hero
worship the investigators.
We've been burned time and time again.
That sometimes that's
just too much pressure
to put on people like
New York AG, Tish James
and Manhattan DA, Cy Vance.
A lot of the criminality
that has been pardoned is purely federal
with respect to lying
to federal prosecutors.
With respect to federal
campaign finance violations
and insider trading.
It's unlikely that a lot of those crimes
have state law counterparts that
could even be investigated and punished,
let alone will be.
That being said,
Paul Manafort was convicted
of numerous different tax crimes.
And it's likely that New York state
has similar state law tax crimes
that he could be charged with.
And even better news,
recently the New York legislature
closed a pardon loophole
that would have prevented prosecution
of someone who receives a pardon
when there is an ancillary
New York state law
to prosecute them under.
So while Paul Manafort was initially
successful in appealing
his New York prosecutions,
it's possible that now
that New York has closed this loophole,
that they can move forward
with prosecuting him on state law crimes.
It's an open question.
We'll see what the New
York appellate courts hold.
You've also likely heard a lot
about the Fifth Amendment,
with respect to being pardoned.
And it is indeed true that
receiving a presidential pardon,
if you accept it,
does limit the scope under which
you can claim the Fifth
Amendment privilege
against self-incrimination.
But it's, unfortunately, not absolute.
If you face state law liability,
then you can still invoke the
Fifth Amendment privilege.
So this will indeed help
both prosecutors and investigators
with respect to inquiries
related to these pardons,
and the underlying criminality.
But it's not going to help
that much, unfortunately.
Additionally, it's possible that
the pardons themselves might be crimes.
Maybe.
I wouldn't put too much stock in this,
but remember that I said
that President Trump
is not going to face criminal
prosecution for these pardons.
Well, it's possible that he might.
There's a slim chance,
but it's possible.
We've seen time and time again
that these members of
the Trump administration,
especially the ones who have been around
since the beginning,
are completely inept.
The DOJ has already gotten wind
of a pardon for purchase scheme
related to Elliott Broidy.
And it's possible that there is
an explicit agreement
between members of the
Trump administration
and these pardons.
It's possible that people did attempt
or were successful at buying a pardon.
You can look at the list of people
who received pardons.
And it's not just Republican cronies
and Trump cronies,
people who actually engaged
in real criminality.
But also those who engaged
in real criminality
and are also just very, very rich.
People that don't necessarily fit
into this category of people
who are being rewarded
by the president for their
service to the president.
People who might have the means
to actually buy a pardon.
And if those explicit
agreements are out there,
it's possible that the
agreement was memorialized
and that emails or documents will leak
that the attorney-client
privilege will be violated
because of the crime/fraud exception.
And someone might talk
after Trump can't actually
pardon people anymore.
If there is an actual, clear quid pro quo
between President Trump
or other members of his administration
and the granting of a pardon,
it could conceivably give rise
to independent criminality
and potential punishment.
That's a big if.
But hopefully, this ends the discussion
about future prosecutions
or at least future investigations.
Past pardons have led
to congressional investigations.
And this one absolutely
needs investigations
if not outright prosecutions.
And if not prosecutions
on a federal level,
then prosecutions on a state law level.
And, hopefully, this
represents the absolute zenith
of presidential power.
At the moment,
The president has never
been more powerful.
The president receives
almost unchecked power
with respect to executive power
and executive privilege.
But these actions are
so far beyond the pale
that I hope it forces
the citizens and members of Congress
to actually act.
To actually put some
real checks and balances,
and to scale back some of the power
that has been granted from Congress
to the presidency.
Make no mistake,
this is a political Rubicon.
This is every bit as bad as it appears.
In some way,
we're lucky that they've
been so ham-fisted about this
because there's no hiding it.
This isn't 4D chess.
This is just plain
cronyism and corruption.
And it's gonna get worse
before it gets better.
Just don't let it wear you down.
But Americans did their part
and they voted overwhelmingly
to send President Trump packing.
We could be looking down the barrel
of four more years of this,
but luckily he will be leaving office.
But there's one last thing to do
which is that we must demand
of the future administrations
that they not let these
pardons go unchecked.
That they cannot allow
this criminality to go unchecked.
We assume that the
president's pardon power
is near universal,
but so much of this is debating
how many angels can dance
on the head of a pin.
Presidential pardons have
rarely been challenged.
We don't know what the Supreme Court
would have said if the
Ford pardon of Nixon
had been challenged,
or the Iran-Contra pardons
had been challenged.
And we don't know what a Supreme Court
would do with these
current raft of pardons.
And we don't know all of the information
about these particular pardons.
Was there an explicit quid pro quo?
Is there independent criminality
about these particular pardons?
The American people have a right to know
that particular information.
Which is why we must demand
that the next administration,
either through the attorney general
or a special prosecutor,
investigate the issuance of these pardons.
Investigate the underlying
criminality itself.
If there is remaining
criminality out there,
charge them, indict them.
Test the sufficiency of the pardon,
test the breadth of the pardons.
And let's see what the
Supreme Court has to say.
And if the Supreme Court
upholds the use of these pardons,
then so be it.
We can demand a constitutional amendment
or other congressional means
to put limits on this power
because that's what Americans deserve.
We fought a war to throw
off the rule of a king.
And these pardons come
as close as Americans ever have
to reverting back to tyranny.
Because as bad as these pardons are,